This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二的保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的全新自我。收听《2%》。这就是数字 2%。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。在每集节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有牌照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约过后，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》节目。相信我，宝贝。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I think this is the first episode in like five episodes where I'm no longer sick and you guys don't have to listen to like a disgusting nasal noise come into your ears. So for that I am grateful and for that I am excited for today's episode. We have another, well I should say I
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁的最大变化、时刻与过渡期，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。我想这是大约五期节目以来，我第一次不再生病，大家也不用再听着我耳朵里传来的恶心的鼻音了。为此我很感激，我也对今天的节目感到兴奋。我们还有另一个，我应该说我
have another mini episode for you today. If you are not familiar with our mini episodes, they're basically kind of smaller bite-sized episodes where we break down a certain phrase, a certain psychological concept that gets thrown around a lot online in TikToks, in dating discourse, in group chats. And essentially we dissect what it actually means according to the psychology rather than according to the pop culture. And today we are tackling, let's be, let's be honest, the most requested, the most weaponized and probably the most misunderstood term and label of them all, we are talking about narcissism. I'm not going to waste any time today because we have so much to talk about, but narcissism is such a fascinating term when you
今天为您准备了另一个迷你播客。如果你对我们的迷你播客不太熟悉，它们基本上是比较短小精悍的单集，我们在其中剖析某个短语，或者经常在网上、TikTok、约会讨论以及群聊中被大量使用的某种心理学概念。本质上，我们是根据心理学而不是流行文化来剖析它真正的含义。今天我们要探讨的，说实话，是所有词汇和标签中最受追捧、最被武器化、也可能最被误解的一个，我们来聊聊自恋。我今天不会浪费时间，因为我们要聊的内容实在太多了，但是自恋是一个非常迷人的词，当你
scratch even below a tiny inch below the surface. And it's also such an ancient term, which I think a lot of people might not know, probably maybe no, given its modern day popularity. So you may have heard of the Greek myth of narcissus before. Basically, this is where the term comes from. Narcissus was this incredibly handsome, striking young man who just really cruelly rejected all of his admirers. So he didn't want anything to do with any of them, all these. beautiful women. This led to the goddess, nemesis, punishing narcissists with an all-consuming love for nothing but his own reflection. So much so that the story goes, he drowned, staring at his reflection in a pond, like so consumed by it, wanting so much more of it. This is where the term
哪怕只是在表面下轻轻刮开一小层。而且它也是一个非常古老的词，考虑到它在现代的流行程度，我想很多人可能并不太清楚，或者大概知道。所以你可能以前听过纳西索斯的希腊神话。基本上，这个词就是由此而来的。纳西索斯是一个极其帅气、令人瞩目的年轻男子，他非常残酷地拒绝了所有的爱慕者。所以他不想和他们中的任何一个人有任何瓜葛，所有这些。美丽的女性。这导致女神涅墨西斯惩罚纳西索斯，让他全神贯注地爱上了除了他自己的倒影之外的任何东西。故事是这样的，他甚至因此淹死了，凝视着池塘里的倒影，如此着迷于它，渴望更多。这就是这个词
basically gets his name from this man, narcissist. It didn't actually become a psychological term until much, much later in the 1800s. In 1898, a theorist, his name was Havlock Ellis, was the first to use the narcissist myth to describe a particular kind of client or person he was seeing. People who were basically just obsessed with themselves. And for him, they were really obsessed with themselves, like, sexually. Like, they truly thought that they were, The hottest thing out, they were really consumed by themselves and he was seeing this pattern of
基本上是以这个男人纳西索斯的名字命名的。直到很久很久以后的 19世纪，它才真正成为一个心理学术语。1898年，一位名叫海夫洛克·埃利斯的理论家首次使用纳西索斯神话来描述他所接触的一种特定类型的客户或人。也就是那些基本上只对他们自己着迷的人。对他来说，这些人真的对他们自己着迷，比如，从性欲的角度。就像他们真的认为自己是，最火辣的人物，他们真的全神贯注于自己，而他看到了这种模式
individual. He also knew the story. That is where narcissism originally got its label. And from there, psychoanalysts like Otto Rank and Sigmund Freud expanded on this to say that narcissism was more of a normal characteristic of someone's personality rather than something that was exclusively sexual. and it was a spectrum that we all kind of sat upon. All of us can be a little bit narcissistic or all of us can have quite a low ego that makes us not narcissistic at all. When it becomes a little bit unbalanced and skewed and when somebody has a bigger, higher dosage, higher level of narcissism compared to all their other traits, that creates
个人。他也知道这个故事。这就是自恋最初的标签来源。从那以后，像奥托·兰克和西格蒙德·弗洛伊德这样的精神分析学家对此进行了扩展，认为自恋更多的是一个人性格中的一种正常特征，而不是某种完全排他的性欲相关的东西。而且它是一个光谱，我们大家多多少少都处于其中。我们所有人都可以有点自恋，或者我们所有人都可以有相当低的自我，这让我们一点也不自恋。当它变得有点不平衡和倾斜，当某个人相比于他的其他所有特质拥有更大、更高剂量的、更高水平的自恋时，这就创造出了
the type of person that we are familiar with, the one who we would say has a, a disordered way of seeing the world and engaging with others because they are a narcissist. So in simple terms, narcissism is a personality trait made up of a cluster of behaviors and smaller traits like one, a heightened sense of self-importance. Two, entitlement to special treatment. Three, a strong need for admiration. And four, low empathy and exploiter live behavior. more broadly, narcissism is often described as closely tied to the pursuit of status.
我们所熟悉的那种人，那种我们认为对世界以及与他人交往有着一种混乱的、失调的看法的人，因为他们是个自恋狂。所以简单来说，自恋是一种人格特质，由一系列行为和较小的特质组成，比如第一，高度的自我重要感。第二，认为自己理应得到特殊对待。第三，对赞美有着强烈的需求。第四，缺乏同理心和剥削性行为。更广泛地说，自恋通常被描述为与追求地位紧密相连。
No matter what, there is this drive within this individual to be impressive, to be the center of attention, to be kind of socially, emotionally, physically untouchable in some kind of way. And that's one of the key points I think gets mixed up pretty often. narcissism is not just high self-esteem and thinking that you are incredible because some people are really incredible. Some people are just really cool and they're successful and they know that and they don't actually need to be humble about it. Healthy self-esteem is this, you know, this is what we would label healthy self-esteem. The basis for their positive, for their positive kind of assumptions about themselves are based in evidence. They are actually an incredible person,
无论如何，这些人的内心都有一种驱动力，那就是要给人留下深刻印象，要成为注意力的中心，要在某种程度上在社交、情感和身体上都是不可触碰的。我认为这是经常被搞混的关键点之一。自恋不仅仅是拥有很高的自尊心并认为自己非常了不起，因为有些人确实非常了不起。有些人就是真的很酷，而且他们很成功，他们知道这一点，实际上并不需要对此保持谦逊。健康的自尊心是这样的，你知道，这就是我们所说的健康的自尊心。他们对自己产生积极的、正面的假设，其基础是有据可依的。他们确实是一个了不起的人，
but also these people can accept criticism and they can bounce back from failure and they can bounce back from not being chosen. They can bounce back from not needing to be the best at something narcissists on the other hand, yes, may present as incredibly confident, yes, may be successful, but what's underneath that is a deep, deep fragility. that gives them an incredibly unhealthy self-esteem that is tied to equal parts their own sense of self-importance and then equal parts the need for everybody else in the room to see them as important. And this fragility, this fragility is what fuels defensiveness, blame, control, contempt for others. They need to maintain their self-image at all costs because with,
但同时这些人也能接受批评，他们能够从失败中恢复过来，也能够从不被选择中恢复过来。他们能够从不需要成为某事第一名的状态中恢复过来。相比之下，自恋者虽然可能表现得极其自信，也可能很成功，但在这一切的背后，却是一种极其深重的脆弱感。这种脆弱感赋予了他们一种极其不健康的自尊，这种自尊一方面与他们自身的自我重要感挂钩，另一方面又等同于需要房间里的所有人都认为他们很重要。正是这种脆弱性，这种脆弱性助长了防御心理、责备、控制以及对他人的蔑视。他们需要不惜一切代价维护自己的自我形象，因为没有了
it, they are just this very fragile, very weak, very scared individual underneath it all. Let's talk about really quickly the distinction between having narcissistic personality disorder and having something that we call basically like having trait narcissism. So just a high level of narcissistic attributes because they are quite different. Narcistic personality disorder is a very real diagnosis. somebody can get this label in their file. And it was first introduced, as we said at the 80s, but it's actually not that common.
这个形象，在这一切的背后，他们其实只是一个非常脆弱、非常软弱、非常恐惧的个体。我们来快速聊聊患有人格障碍和我们基本上称之为拥有特质自恋之间的区别。也就是仅仅具有较高水平的自恋属性，因为这两者截然不同。自恋型人格障碍是一个非常真实的诊断。某个人的档案里确实可以贴上这个标签。正如我们前面所说，它最早是在 80年代被引入的，但它其实并不那么常见。
Narcissistic personality disorder, I think it has a prevalence of anywhere between 0.2 to like 0.6% of the population. And that's mainly based on US population studies. It is actually around 50 to 75% more common in males than females. males, but some people have said that's just because women may be better at hiding it than men are because of this social conditioning to be more humble, even if that's not the way they truly feel. The key thing that the American Psychiatric Association highlights, though, is that, again, to get to this point of being like, you are disordered, you have a serious problem.
自恋型人格障碍，我想它的患病率大约在人口的 0.2% 到 0.6% 之间。这主要基于美国的人口研究。实际上，男性的患病率比女性高出大约 50% 到 75%。但有些人说，那只是因为女性可能比男性更擅长隐藏这一点，因为这种社会条件要求她们表现得更加谦逊，即便这并不是她们内心真实的感受。不过，美国精神医学学会强调的关键点是，同样地，要达到这种被判定为“你有障碍，你有一个严重问题”的地步。
Something, it has to be very drastic. Most people don't get this diagnosis, unless, you know, they've experienced several marriage breakdowns. They've come to contact with the court system. They have been an abusive partner. Like, it's quite difficult, actually, to get that label. In most cases, when we encounter somebody who thinks very highly of themselves, is very desperate to seem successful and admirable, they may not have a diagnosis.
有些情况必须非常极端。大多数人是不会得到这个诊断的，除非，你知道，他们经历过多次婚姻破裂。他们接触过法院系统。他们曾是一个虐待成性的伴侣。所以，要得到这个标签其实是相当困难的。在大多数情况下，当我们遇到一个自我感觉极好、极度渴望显得成功和令人钦佩的人时，他们可能并没有确诊。
They may not be worthy of a diagnosis. but they may be high in this thing that I just mentioned called trait narcissism. Trait narcissism is not a disorder. It's basically a personality style. It is a set of tendencies you can kind of score higher or lower on and doesn't automatically mean that, again, you have a disorder. Trait narcissism, the thing that we are more commonly encountering, basically shows up in two very broad forms. The first is grandiose narcissism. So this, This is the typical idea of narcissism that we see. Grandiose narcissism is the big inflated ego, it's social dominance, it's this larger than life personality.
他们可能并不符合诊断标准。但他们在刚才提到的“特质自恋”这一项上可能得分很高。特质自恋并不是一种障碍。它基本上是一种人格风格。它是一组你可以得分高一点或低姆的倾向，并不自动意味着，同样地，你就有精神障碍。特质自恋，也就是我们更常遇到这种情况，基本上以两种非常广泛的形式出现。第一种是显性自恋。所以，这就是我们看到的自恋的典型概念。显性自恋就是膨胀的自我、社会支配欲，这种超越常人的个性。
Sometimes these people can come off as really charming and really persuasive, but they can also be very aggressive and very entitled. This is the idea, again, we know most often, I'm sure you can think of a couple of political or cultural examples going on at the moment. The second distinct form of narcissism is vulnerable narcissism. This is the person that we don't always notice, but who is a lot more insidious and sometimes harmful. Because their pattern of behaviours doesn't look like arrogance. Really, it's about emotional insecurity and defensiveness. they are easily hurt, they are easily embarrassed, they're easily threatened, and so what they end up doing is trying to put you down, trying to emotionally manipulate their surroundings so that they are always the victim,
有时这些人会显得非常迷人、极具说服力，但他们也可能极具攻击性且充满特权意识。这就是我们最常见的那种自恋的概念，我确信你能想到目前正在发生的一两个政治或文化方面的例子。自恋的第二种不同形式是隐性自恋。这就是我们并不总能注意到，但却更具隐蔽性、有时也更有害的人。因为他们的行为模式看起来并不像傲慢。实际上，这与情感上的不安全感和防御心理有关。他们很容易受伤，很容易感到尴尬，很容易受到威胁，所以他们最终会做的是试图贬低你，试图在情感上操纵他们周围的环境，以便他们永远是受害者，
so that they always get special treatment, so that no matter what, they are at the center of attention. But it's this interesting thing where the reason they're at the center over the attention, center of attention isn't always because of their achievements. Sometimes it's because of their pain and suffering. Sometimes it's because they're the one who always has the most dramatic story that they need to one up everybody else in the room with. This is vulnerable narcissism.
以便他们总是能得到特殊对待，以便无论如何，他们都是注意力的中心。但这是一个有趣的现象，他们成为焦点的原因、注意力的中心并不总是因为他们的成就。有时是因为他们的痛苦和磨难。有时是因为他们总是能讲出最戏剧性的故事，并以此在房间里的所有人面前争强好胜。这就是隐性自恋。
Now, here's where it gets even more interesting because psychologists have basically realized that just saying grandiose versus vulnerable trait narcissism still doesn't fully explain it. more recent models, break it down into three core components. The first component of what makes somebody's narcissistic personality is antagonism. And this tends to show up in both grandiose and vulnerable narcissism. Antagonism is that entitlement, that exploitiveness, that desire to get what you want. It's when there is an assumption from somebody that the rules don't apply to me. I can get away with whatever I want to. And the people around me, they're not just people. They are resources. They are status symbols. They are threats. They are something that can be
现在，更有意思的地方来了，因为心理学家基本上意识到，仅仅区分显性与隐性特质自恋仍然无法完全解释这一点。更新的模型将其拆解为三个核心成分。构成某人自恋人格的第一个成分是对抗性。这往往在显性和隐性自恋中都会表现出来。对抗性就是那种特权意识、剥削性、以及得到你想要的渴望。当某人有一种假设，认为规则不适用于我。我可以随心所欲，为所欲为。而我周围的人，不仅仅是人。他们是资源。他们是地位的象征。他们是威胁。他们是可以被
manipulated. I can antagonize them. I can manipulate them into doing what I want them to. component two is something called a gentic extraversion and this is more commonly and closely linked to grandiose narcissism basically social dominance assertiveness charisma this again looks like somebody who needs to be the leader they need to be the most impressive successful person the loudest person, the most, the smartest person, in a very specific kind of way. And then the final and third and final component is narcissistic neuroticism. And this is where, I know I'm really drilling home this point, but this is where vulnerable and grandiose narcissism differ.
操纵的对象。我可以与他们对抗。我可以操纵他们来做我想让他们做的事。第二个成分被称为代理性外向，这与显性自恋更常见、更紧密地联系在一起。基本上就是社会支配欲、自信、个人魅力。这同样看起来像是一个需要成为领导者的人，他们需要成为最令人印象深刻、最成功的人，最喧闹的人，最聪明的人，而且是以一种非常具体的方式。然后是最后、第三个也是最后一个成分，那就是自恋神经质。这就是——我知道我真的在反复强调这一点，但这就是隐性自恋和显性自恋的不同之处。
Because somebody with vulnerable narcissism might not have that extraversion, but what they will have is this real sensitivity to criticism. and almost this like split. I don't want to say split personality because that's not what it is, but it does give that appearance of this person is really nice. They're so innocent. They're so kind. They're so lovely.
因为患有隐性自恋的人可能没有那种外向性，但他们所拥有的是对批评的真正敏感度。几乎有种分裂的感觉。我不想说这是分裂人格，因为事实并非如此，但它确实给人一种错觉：这个人真的很不错。他们太无辜了。他们太善良了。他们太可爱了。
They've had such a hard time. And then when somebody does criticize them, when they are not the center of attention, they go in for the kill. They see you now as a threat. They need to annihilate your character. They become very defensive. They become angry.
他们经历了如此艰难的时期。然后，当有人批评他们，当他们不是注意力的中心时，他们就会下狠手。他们现在把你视为威胁。他们需要彻底抹杀你的人格。他们变得极具防御性。他们变得愤怒。
they become resentful, they become withdrawn. And this is why, you know, both those types of individuals have trait narcissism, but they look so different. And I think that vulnerable narcissism we're talking about is the kind that, again, is so insidious. You maybe can notice it in the relationship you have with family members or a friend where you are having this very different experience to what other people are having with this person because they haven't been able to see through this
他们变得心怀怨恨，变得孤僻。这就是为什么，你知道，这两种类型的人都具有特质自恋，但他们看起来截然不同。而且我认为我们正在谈论的隐性自恋是那种同样具有极强隐蔽性的类型。你也许能在你与家庭成员或朋友的关系中注意到这一点，在那里你有着与其他人对这个人的体验完全不同的经历，因为他们还没能看穿这种
kind of mask yet and see what these behaviors and this personality, this pattern of personality really is, which is that this person needs to be the most important. And going about it the grandiose way, maybe hasn't worked for them. So this is the new way they're going to do it. Equally through emotional manipulation, but through a different kind of emotional manipulation. So how do you actually spot a real narcissist? I want to be really careful here. You cannot diagnose narcissistic personality disorder from the outside. You cannot diagnose it from one argument,
面具，也没有看出这些行为以及这种人格、这种人格模式到底是什么，即这个人需要成为最重要的人。而用显性的方式去争取，对他们来说可能行不通。所以这是他们将要采取的新方式。同样是通过情感操纵，但却是通过另一种不同的情感操纵。那么，你到底该如何识别一个真正的自恋者呢？我在这里想格外谨慎。你不能从外表诊断自恋型人格障碍。你不能从一次争吵中诊断出它，
and you definitely can't diagnose it from somebody just being a little bit frustrating or a little bit egocentric. We all mess up in public spaces sometimes. We all have moments of being a little bit grandiose. We all have moments where we've definitely dominated a conversation or we've been a little bit selfish. That doesn't necessarily give somebody a disordered way of thinking. And it doesn't necessarily make them high in trait narcissism unless it is a continued pattern. And even then, I would be very wary of saying, this person has NPD.
而且你绝对不能仅仅因为某人有点沮丧或有点以自我为中心就诊断出它。我们在公共场所有时都会搞砸。我们都有过表现得有点显赫的时刻。我们都有过绝对主导了一场对话或者有点自私的时刻。这并不一定赋予某人一种紊乱的思维方式。而且除非这是一种持续的模式，否则这并不一定意味着他们在特质自恋上得分很高。即便如此，我也会对说“这个人患有 NPD”保持高度警惕。
I would probably say this person is high in narcissistic traits. But here are some questions to ask yourself. If you genuinely think somebody is this and is this kind of full. in your life. Number one, do you think this person actually cares about you or do they care about what you can do for them? Do you believe this person sees you as they're equal? Number two, do they take on board criticism well? Very easy. Number three, are they always at the center of things? Or do they let people tag in to the spotlight. Number four, do different rules apply to them compared to everybody else? And can you see that in their behavior? Number five, do they always need to be
我可能会说这个人的自恋特质很高。但这里有一些问题你可以问问自己。如果你真的认为某个人是这样的人，并且在你的生活中如此充斥着这种特质。第一，你认为这个人真的在乎你吗，还是他们在乎你能为他们做什么？你相信这个人把你当成他们的平等的人吗？第二，他们能很好地听取批评吗？非常简单。第三，他们总是处于事情的中心吗？还是他们会让别人也进入聚光灯下？第四，与其他人相比，他们是否适用不同的规则？你能在他们的行为中看到这一点吗？第五，他们总是需要
superior to be admired? Or do they always have to be right? Even if it costs you, your dignity and your reputation and your well-being. Basically, do you believe that you have a genuine relationship or are you just a porn? Let's pause here. Those questions are useful. I also know what a lot of you guys are thinking. Oh my God, what if that's me? Am I a narcissist? I can relate to sometimes not taking criticism well. I can relate to sometimes wanting the spotlight. I like to be right. Every time I talk about narcissism, I always think that I'm a narcissist. Always.
高人一等才能受到赞赏吗？还是他们总是必须是对的？即使这要以你的尊严、你的名誉和你的福祉为代价。基本上，你认为你拥有的这段关系是真诚的，还是你只是一个棋子？我们在这里暂停一下。这些问题很有用。我也知道你们很多人在想什么。天哪，如果那是我呢？我是自恋狂吗？我能理解有时无法接受批评。我能理解有时渴望聚光灯。我喜欢当对的那个。每次我谈论自恋时，我总是认为我是一个自恋狂。总是这样。
I don't know why. And every time I make an episode or I mention narcissism, I always get questions and comments from people being like, is that me? Can you diagnose me? Can you tell me if I'm one of these people? So I'm going to give you a little bit of a personal checklist as well to rule out or rule in. Maybe you are a narcissist. You're probably not.
我不知道为什么。而且每次我制作一集节目或提到自恋时，我总是收到人们的问题和评论，比如，那是我吗？你能给我诊断吗？你能告诉我我是不是这些人的其中之一吗？所以我也会给你一个小型的个人检查清单来排除或确认。也许你是个自恋狂。你大概不是。
but to rule out that you are probably, probably not. Can you apologize without adding, but you made me? Yes or no. When you are criticized, do you genuinely care about why? Do you genuinely try to change your behavior? Or do you just attack and deflect? Do you treat people as whole humans or just as an audience? when you feel insecure in a situation at work,
但为了排除你可能，大概不是。你能在道歉时加上“但是你逼我的”吗？是或否。当你受到批评时，你真的关心原因吗？你真的试图改变你的行为吗？还是你只是攻击并转移话题？你把人当作完整的人类还是仅仅当作观众？当你在工作中的某个情境中感到没有安全感时，
do you try and repair the situation? Do you try and take time away and examine your insecurity? Or do you just try and dominate other people in the space? Can you be wrong? Can you be wrong? Have you been wrong in the last little while? It's a great litmus test. Are you actually interested in other?
你会试图修复这种情况吗？你会试图花时间离开并审视你的不安全感吗？还是你只是试图支配空间里的其他人？你能犯错吗？你能犯错吗？你在最近的一段时间里犯过错吗？这是一个极好的试金石。你真的对其他人的生活感兴趣吗？
people's lives. That is the litmus test. Those are the questions that I always give people or always think of when that thought comes into my head. I also know, even just questioning, am I a narcissist, shows me, shows you guys that you're probably not because if you were a narcissist, your ego most likely wouldn't even let you consider that as a possibility. So it's this funny irony, right? Thinking that you are probably means that you aren't. You are very much safe here. Okay, let's take a short break because after this we need to zoom out and talk about why this word has exploded culturally and whether we are actually becoming more narcissistic as a society. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
人们的生活。这就是试金石。每当这个想法涌上心头时，我总是会把这些问题抛给别人，或者自己也会想到这些。我也知道，仅仅是质疑“我是自恋狂吗”，就向我、向你们大家表明，你们大概不是，因为如果你是一个自恋狂，你的自我很可能甚至不允许你把这当作一种可能性来考虑。所以这真是个有趣的讽刺，对吧？认为自己可能是，大概意味着你其实不是。你在这里非常安全。好了，我们休息一小会儿，因为休息过后，我们需要放宽视野，聊聊为什么这个词在文化上会大爆发，以及作为一个社会，我们是否真的变得越来越自恋了。所以请继续关注我们。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardship.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦。
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
你将会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的全新自我在另一边出现。收听《2%》。也就是 2%。在 I-Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMAs 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。在每集节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
欢迎来到我的新播客节目《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾展开对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different
已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
意图，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一支大军来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的世界观崩塌了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被控诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So we are obviously hearing the term narcissism a whole lot more.
法则二，也绝对不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约过后。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。
Is that because narcissism is actually increasing in society? or just because it's become a bit of a phenomenon, because it's just become a source of fascination. The thing is, researchers aren't really that short because society has become more individualistic. It has become more narcissist friendly with the rise of social media. Is that just meaning that narcissistic voices or narcissistic individuals, they are getting more of a spotlight?
所以他们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》节目。相信我，宝贝。所以我们显然更频繁地听到“自恋”这个词了。
or is the underlying prevalence actually increasing? So in 2008, researchers from San Diego State University, they published their decades-long findings on this very question. They had a sample of over 16,000 people that they basically looked at between the years of 1979 and 2006. They wanted to see across these, quick my math, 30 years, let's say, across these 30 years, are we seeing an increase or is it something else at play? That's a lot of people.
这是因为自恋在社会中实际上在增加吗？还是仅仅因为它已经变成了一种现象，因为它已经成为一种着迷的源头？问题是，研究人员并不十分确定，因为社会已经变得更加个人主义。随着社交媒体的崛起，它变得对自恋者更加友好。这是否仅仅意味着自恋的声音或自恋的个人，他们获得了更多的关注？
And what they found was that there was a 30% increase in narcissistic traits based on the earlier years average. So every year they were seeing a slight 30% uptick. Now, you have to remember, that's not 30% on like already half of this population had narcissism or had high narcissistic traits. This was like a 30% optic on like 0.2 and then on 0.5 and then on 1% and then on 2%. So it still was quite minor. But when you hear 30%, you really, your eyes kind of go wide of like, oh my God, does that really mean like one in three people around me are high in narcissism? Not necessarily. That is just one finding. And it definitely gets more complicated as to where
还是潜在的患病率实际上在增加？因此，在2008年，来自圣迭戈大学的研究人员发表了他们对这个确切问题的几十年的研究发现。他们有一个样本，包括超过 16,000 人，基本上考察了 1979 年到 2006 年之间的情况。他们希望看到在这期间，稍微计算一下，30 年，比方说，在这 30 年里，我们看到的是在增加还是有其他因素在起作用？这可是很多人。
the narcissism is just more visible or more prevalent. A more recent 2004 large-scale meta-analysis challenged this idea that we have a narcissism epidemic. Researchers, they pulled results from over a thousand papers looking at narcissism scores using that same measure they used in the San Diego study. And they looked at it globally from a little bit of a longer period, 1982 to 2023. And what was important about the study is that it also included, you know, the 2010s and the early 2020s where social media really blew up. They actually found that narcissistic traits were pretty stable in the 80s and 90s. They then actually decreased in the 2000s and in more recent decades, which completely contrasts
他们发现的是，基于早年平均水平，自恋特质增加了 30%。所以每年他们都会看到轻微的 30% 的上升。现在，你必须记住，这并不是说在已经有一半人口患有自恋或高度自恋特质的基础上增加 30%。这就像是在 0.2% 的基础上上升 30%，然后在 0.5%，然后在 1%，然后在 2%。所以它实际上仍然相当微小。但当你听到 30% 时，你的眼睛真的会睁大，会想，天哪，这真的意味着我周围每三个人中就有一个人自恋倾向很高吗？不一定。这只是一项发现。而且，关于自恋到底是变得更明显了还是更普遍了，情况绝对要复杂得多。一项更新的 2004 年的大规模元分析挑战了我们拥有自恋大流行这种观念。研究人员从一千多篇论文中提取了结果，使用圣迭戈研究中使用的相同衡量标准来观察自恋得分。他们从一个稍长一点的时期（1982 年到 2023 年）对其进行了全球范围的考察。这项研究的重要之处在于，它还包括了社交媒体真正爆发的 2010 年代和 2020 年代初期。他们实际上发现，自恋特质在 80 年代和 90 年代相当稳定。随后，它们在 2000 年代以及最近几十年实际上有所下降，这与之前的研究形成了鲜明对比。
the previous study. Here is my take that nobody asked for, but a. I'm going to give it to you in the spirit of self-centeredness and narcissism. I just think that our culture has made narcissism and the visibility of narcissism rise to the surface. It's not actually increased it. The genuine level of true narcissism and people who truly have narcissistic personality disorder is pretty stable. They're definitely still out there. It's just given us much more visibility of people who may have higher rates,
这是我的观点，虽然没人问过，但是。为了展现自我中心和自恋，我要把它分享给你们。我只是认为我们的文化让自恋和自恋的可见性浮出了水面。它并没有真正增加。真正的自恋以及真正患有自恋型人格障碍的人的真实水平是相当稳定的。他们绝对还在那里。它只是让我们更能看到那些可能拥有更高比例的
of this trait, especially because those kinds of people who do like attention and who do like being the center and who do have a strong ego, they thrive in online spaces. They really do. Like being a narcissistic, not being a narcissist, having high narcissistic traits would make social media a lot easier for you. I think it would also make it a lot harder for you as well because obviously you get to a certain level of fame and you are going to get criticism and that's when we see people get really reactive and very angry. That's like a very big sign. But, you know, we have built this world where it's easier than ever to manage your self-worth externally through metrics, through visibility, through likes, through follow account, through, you know, a curated identity. And that self-presentation
这种特质的人，特别是由于那些喜欢关注、喜欢成为中心、并且拥有强烈自我的人，他们在网络空间中茁壮成长。他们真的是这样。就像做一个自恋者——不是作为一个自恋者，而是拥有高度的自恋特质——会让社交媒体对你来说容易得多。我认为这也会让你的日子难过得多，因为显然你达到了某种名气水平，你就会受到批评，而这就是我们看到人们变得极具反应性和非常愤怒的时候。这是一个非常大的标志。但是，你知道，我们已经建立了一个这样一个世界，通过指标、通过曝光度、通过点赞、通过粉丝数、通过精选的身份，比以往任何时候都更容易在外部管理你的自我价值。而这种自我展示
is rewarded. Now again, let's be careful here. Wanting attention, wanting to blow up online, wanting to post more content, liking yourself, does not make you a narcissist. There are people out there who are truly very manipulative and do not want to change and who cause a whole lot of pain. So we have to be really careful with overusing this term. If everyone is a narcissist, if it continues to be this casual phrase, then the word stops holding as much power and needing as much attention in cases where someone is genuinely problematic, maybe even dangerous. I think the other issue without overuse is that it can invalidate people who have lived through
得到了回报。现在再次强调，我们要小心。渴望关注、渴望在网上爆红、渴望发布更多内容、喜欢自己，并不等于你就是一个自恋者。外面确实有一些人非常具有操纵性、不想改变，并造成了大量的痛苦。所以我们在过度使用这个词时必须非常谨慎。如果每个人都是自恋者，如果它继续成为这样一个随意的短语，那么当真正出现问题、甚至可能具有危险性的案例时，这个词将不再具有那么大的力量，也不再需要那么多的关注。我认为过度使用的另一个问题是，它会使那些经历过
a genuine pattern of narcissistic abuse or narcissistic control that, and they just want to be taken seriously. They just want people to really see the pattern that they have gone through without people assuming that they're just being dramatic or they're just latching on to the new buzz hype word. Think about cases of, again, narcissistic abuse or workplace harassment. It can turn, this overuse can turn their experience into just another internet buzzword. And it
真实的自恋虐待或自恋控制模式的人的经历失效，而他们只是想被认真对待。他们只是希望人们真正看到他们所经历的模式，而不是让人以为他们只是在小题大做，或者他们只是在蹭新的流行热词。再想想自恋虐待或职场骚扰的案例。这种过度使用可以将他们的经历变成又一个互联网流行词。而且
makes it easier again for outsiders to dismiss it as, oh, it's just another bit of breakup or it's, you know, everybody's boss is a little bit narcissistic. Everybody, everybody's boss is a little bit terrible. Rather than recognizing that for some people, it was prolonged manipulation, prolonged character assassination, coercion, psychological harm, and they are paying the price, whether it was in a relationship, whether it was with a parent, with a sibling, with a friend, with a boss, with a co-worker. Because of this, I would honestly say, we need to widen our vocabulary a little bit for why somebody we may think as a narcissist, why it was that their behavior is so off or so painful without just slapping on the easiest label we can find.
这再次让外人更容易将其轻描淡写地视为“哦，这不过是又一次分手”或者“你知道的，每个人的老板都有点自恋。每个人，每个人的老板都有点糟糕”。而不是去认识到，对某些人来说，这是长期的操纵、长期的性格暗杀、强迫、心理伤害，而他们正在为此付出代价，无论是在恋爱关系中，还是与父母、兄弟姐妹、朋友、老板、同事相处时。正因为如此，我老实说，我们需要稍微拓宽一下我们的词汇量，来解释为什么我们认为某人是自恋者时，为什么他们的行为如此反常或如此痛苦，而不仅仅是贴上我们能找到的最简单的标签。
I think this also may help us privately understand what we've been through and understand our pain. But, you know, the narcissist label, it may be a shortcut that does a disservice. What were you actually experiencing? What about this person was truly, you know, difficult to endure? Were they manipulative? Were they domineering? Did they never let you speak? Did they never let you control the friendship or control the relationship?
我想这也可能有助于我们在私下理解我们所经历的一切，并理解我们的痛苦。但是，你知道，“自恋者”这个标签可能是一条捷径，反而帮了倒忙。你当时实际的经历是什么？这个人身上究竟有什么是真正难以忍受的？他们有操控欲吗？他们盛气凌人吗？他们从来不让你说话吗？他们从来不让你掌控这段友谊或这段关系吗？
Did they never ask you how your day was? Did they never consider your life? Did they make you something to manipulate to make others like them? Were they hostile, cruel, unthinking, dismissing. dismissive. Again, widen that vocabulary. I think it's actually a very healing thing to not just use that label, but actually be able to articulate why someone's behavior is harmful, not just for you, but for them as well, so that if they, you know, aren't actually a narcissist, they can change and they can identify, hopefully, or have some self-awareness as to what exactly you. You know, you're not actually,
他们从来不问你今天过得怎么样吗？他们从来不考虑你的生活吗？他们把你当作操纵的工具来让别人喜欢他们吗？他们充满敌意、残酷、冷漠、不屑一顾吗？再说一次，拓宽你的词汇量。我认为，不仅不使用那个标签，而且能够清楚地表达为什么某人的行为是有害的——不仅对你，对他们也是如此——这其实是一件非常具有治愈意义的事。这样一来，如果他们其实并不是真正的自恋者，他们就可以改变，并且能够识别出来（希望如此），或者对你究竟在经历什么有一定的自我意识……
you were bothered by, rather than just hearing you call them a narcissist and being like, well, that person doesn't know what they're talking about. The more specific, I think, the more power. Let's circle back to that thing I said, that I've kind of just completely glazed over. Can true narcissists change? That is our final question of the day. If you just looked online, the general consensus would be no. And I get why that idea is really popular. If you've been hurt by somebody who repeatedly denies your reality, who has twisted blame back onto you, who has treated your feelings like an inconvenience, the idea that they're incapable of change is really comforting. Because it makes the chaos make sense, right?
你所烦恼的是什么，而不仅仅是听到你称他们为自恋者，然后觉得“这个人根本不知道自己在说什么”。我认为，越具体，力量就越大。让我们回到我刚才说的那个被我一笔带过的问题。真正的自恋者能改变吗？这是我们今天最后一个问题。如果你只看网络上的言论，普遍的共识是不能。我明白为什么这种观点如此受欢迎。如果你曾经被一个不断否定你的现实、把责任推卸给你、把你的感情视为麻烦的人伤害过，那么“他们无法改变”这种想法其实是让人感到安慰的。因为这让混乱变得合情合理了，对吧？
And it makes the outcome feel inevitable, not personal. The sad reality is that the truth is more nuanced. People with narcissistic personality disorder or narcissistic traits, there is evidence they can change. or that they can give the appearance of change, as some people would speculate, it doesn't make it easy. The first thing to understand is that narcissistic behaviors often function like a protective system. And this isn't to say you have to have empathy for this person who has hurt you. You have to understand why they are the way they are. But, you know, these aren't just random bad habits.
并且它让结果看起来像是不可避免的，而不是针对你个人的。可悲的现实是，真相要复杂得多。患有自恋型人格障碍或有自恋特质的人，有证据表明他们是可以改变的，或者正如有些人猜测的那样，他们可以表现出改变的样子，但这并不容易。首先要了解的是，自恋行为通常起到一种保护系统的作用。这并不是说你必须对这个伤害过你的人产生同理心。你必须理解他们为什么会成为这样的人。但是，你知道，这些并不仅仅是随机的坏习惯。
These are patterns of self-protection, which is why they are so. stubborn because you're not just asking somebody to stop being arrogant. You are asking them to tolerate emotions that their ego and their self finds unbearable. Things like shame, inadequacy, a sense of worthlessness, vulnerability. So that is why forcing change or even asking a narcissist to change does seem so impossible because it requires two things. Number one, One being insight, they actually have to see that there is a problem with their behavior and acknowledge that they have hurt people. That's difficult for anybody to admit, but especially hard when your identity is built around
这些是自我保护的模式，这就是为什么它们如此顽固，因为你不仅仅是要求某人停止傲慢。你是要求他们去忍受那些他们的自我和心理觉得无法承受的情绪。比如羞耻感、无能感、毫无价值感、脆弱感。所以这就是为什么强迫改变甚至要求自恋者改变似乎是不可能的原因，因为它需要两个条件。第一点是洞察力，他们必须真正看到自己的行为存在问题，并承认他们伤害了别人。这对任何人来说都很难承认，但当你的身份建立在……
being right and being special and being untouchable. The other thing they need is motivation. You know, many people with more entrenched narcissistic patents, they don't seek help because they don't actually experience themselves as a problem. So yes, they may be able to look back and see this pattern of broken relationships and this pattern of people being very angry with them. But they don't have the motivation to change because on another level, they're very successful. They're making a ton of money. They are a leader.
正确、特别和不可侵犯的基础之上时，就尤其困难。他们需要的另一件事是动机。你知道，许多有根深蒂固的自恋模式的人，他们不寻求帮助，因为他们实际上并不觉得自己是个问题。所以是的，他们可能会回过头来看到这种破裂关系的模式，看到人们对他们非常愤怒的模式。但他们没有改变的动机，因为在另一个层面上，他们非常成功。他们赚了大量的钱。他们是一个领导者。
They believe they have respect. So this trait is also helping them. Often what therapists will find when they do encounter, the rare individual with narcissistic personality disorder in a clinical setting is that often it's somebody else dragging them to the table. A relationship is going to end. This marriage is going to fall apart. You have done something terrible at work. Your reputation is taking a huge hit. They're in the prison setting. They are in a, you know, they have committed a crime. In other words, suffering and the disordered nature of this has become so undeniable that either through some miracle they have brought
他们相信自己受到了尊重。所以这种特质也在帮助他们。通常，治疗师在临床环境中偶尔遇到患有自恋型人格障碍的罕见个体时，会发现通常是其他人硬拖着他们来的。这段关系要结束了。这段婚姻要破裂了。你在工作上做了可怕的事情。你的声誉受到了沉重打击。他们身处监狱。他们（你知道的）犯罪了。换句话说，痛苦和这种失常的本质已经变得如此不可否认，以至于要么通过某种奇迹他们自己来到了……
themselves in or a system or a person has pushed them into a therapy setting, that is how they end up there. Let's say this, even if this person is able to change and is able to develop empathy and a stable sense of self and is able to see the issue with their behavior, it's not going to happen quickly and it may not happen at all. but there is a chance, there is a small chance, and it's kind of this thing, this dilemma where it's like people who genuinely have narcissistic personality disorder, what do we meant to do with them in society? You know, hope that they get what they want, hope that like they are skillful enough to not hurt people in their manipulation, no, like if there is this 1% let's say of people just operating out there,
治疗机构，要么是某个系统或某人把他们推进了治疗机构，他们就是这样走到这一步的。打个比方，即使这个人能够改变，能够培养出同理心和一个稳定的自我感，并且能够看到自己行为中的问题，这也不会很快发生，甚至可能根本不会发生。但还是有机会的，有一个小小的机会。这就陷入了一种两难境地：对于那些真正患有自恋型人格障碍的人，我们在社会上该拿他们怎么办？你知道，指望他们得到他们想要的，指望他们足够老练，在操纵时不伤害别人吗？不，如果这1%的人在外面活动……
what do we do with them? And people have to believe there has to be the sense that they can change. There has to be some kind of optimism for the role of therapy. The thing is, and what is always going to come up in this discussion is with somebody who truly has these traits. Do they change or do they just learn a new way of operating? Do they just learn a new set of behaviours that are equally manipulative, which is to fake humility? and to fake self-deprecation and to fake empathy as a disguise for true self-awareness, which is that they are aware they have a problem,
我们该拿他们怎么办？人们必须相信，必须有一种他们能够改变的感觉。对治疗的作用必须有某种乐观的态度。问题是，也是这场讨论中永远会出现的问题是，对于一个真正有这些特质的人来说，他们是真的改变了，还是只是学会了一种新的运作方式？他们只是学会了一套同样具有操纵性、用来伪装谦卑、伪装自我贬低、伪装同理心的行为吗？以此来掩饰真正的自我意识——即他们意识到自己有问题……
or they are at least aware that people don't enjoy their behavior. They want to be liked. So the manipulation or the, I guess, their behavior then tells them that this is the better way to act in this new situation to continue being liked, which is to basically fake the behaviors that others want to see in them. And you know what? How do we know? How do we ever know that somebody who has been through therapy for narcissistic traits
或者他们至少意识到人们不喜欢他们的行为。他们想被人喜欢。所以操纵，或者说他们的行为告诉他们，在这个新情况下，为了继续被人喜欢，表现得更好，基本上就是伪装出别人希望看到的行为。你知道吗？我们怎么知道？我们怎么能知道一个经历过自恋特质治疗的人……
or narcissistic personality disorder has genuinely changed or they are faking it? And the thing is, we don't. Like, we don't really until moments of like vulnerability or until moments of outrage when like somebody is pushed really, really far. that's the point where we can tell. And those situations are often so rare for a narcissist to be in. So as we wrap up this episode, I hope that it has given you more of a psychological insight into the different ways that narcissism, narcissistic traits, narcissistic personality disorder
或自恋型人格障碍的人是真正改变了，还是在伪装？问题是，我们不知道。真的不知道，直到出现脆弱的时刻，或者直到被人逼得非常非常紧而大发雷霆的时刻。这就是我们能辨别的时候。而对于自恋者来说，这种情况通常非常罕见。因此，在我们结束本期节目之际，我希望它能为您提供更多关于自恋、自恋特质、自恋型人格障碍在社会中表现出来的不同方式的心理学见解。
shows up in our society. It is not as straightforward as TikTok or social media or the internet. might make it seem. And I think that's really important to acknowledge for people who have genuinely endured really terrible behaviours and really terrible manipulation from people who kind of blur the lines and who don't outright look like narcissists, don't outright have a diagnosis but still have done terrible things. And also for, I also think hopefully it's given you some clarity around why it's important to use a more specific label for people's behaviour rather than just jumping to the narcissistic conclusion. People with true
它并不像TikTok、社交媒体或互联网所描绘的那样简单。我认为，对于那些真正忍受了可怕行为以及来自那些模糊了界限、没有明确表现得像自恋者、没有明确诊断但仍然做了可怕事情的人的可怕操纵的人来说，承认这一点真的很重要。同时我也希望，这能让你更加清楚，为什么对人们的行为使用更具体的标签，而不是直接跳到自恋的结论上，是多么重要。真正患有……
narcissistic personality disorder are quite rare in society and often actually they are very hard to identify because of how intense their condition is and how great they are at manipulating us. So I think and I hope it's just giving you something to think about, you know, what is a narcissist? When does somebody deserve that label? Should I be using that label as often as I do or as I want to? And what are kind of the alternatives? Thank you as always for tuning into this episode. Thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her help on this episode as well, and for looking through all of those meta-analysis for such interesting data. Make sure, as always, that you are following us, wherever you are listening, make sure that you are subscribed so that you
自恋型人格障碍的人在社会上相当罕见，而且由于他们的病情有多严重以及他们在操纵我们方面有多厉害，通常实际上很难识别他们。所以我认为也希望这能给你一些启示：什么是自恋者？什么样的人才配得上这个标签？我应该像现在这样经常或想要使用这个标签吗？有什么替代方案吗？一如既往，感谢收听本期节目。感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的帮助，感谢她查阅了所有这些元分析以获取如此有趣的数据。和往常一样，无论你在哪里收听，请确保关注我们，确保订阅我们，以便……
get new episodes when they come out on Tuesdays and Fridays. Also that you're following us on Instagram, on Substack, if you want to read versions of episodes like this. If you want them delivered into your inbox, that is the place to go. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science
当周二和周五新节目发布时你能收到通知。另外，如果你想阅读像这样的节目文本版本，请在Instagram、Substack上关注我们。如果你想让它们发送到你的收件箱，去那里就对了。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己好一点。我们很快就会交谈。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了……
of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健康和建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big. speak to me.
那是iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的《2%》。在播客节目《回顾过去》中。从1979年开始，对我和说对我来说那是一个巨大的时刻。84年很大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。那是一个狂野的年份。那是一个狂野的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist. Most care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师带来的《知难而进》。最关心的游戏。这个空间关乎黑男性的经验，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在任何地方其实都不安全，但你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须去这样做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰奇尼（Michael Ranchini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听女友的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。